You know that nightmare in all the TV shows,
where you’re standing in front of a podium,
you look down, and you’re not wearing any
clothing?
That split second of terror when the audience
is laughing at you and you feel unprepared,
helpless, alone, and so cold, is excruciating.
We’re here to help you avoid that feeling
in real life, whether you’re on a stage
or in a one-on-one meeting with your boss.
So take a deep breath, and get ready to improve
your public speaking skills to make sure your
ideas stick.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets.
And this is Crash Course Business: Soft Skills.
[Intro Music Plays]
We’ve all survived book reports and group
projects in school, but public speaking isn’t
always standing in front of a slide deck.
Depending on your job, you may need to sell
an idea with a pitch or give a talk to a crowd
But you’ll also need to contribute to meetings.
Or just chat with your coworkers.
And if you’re in your mid-twenties, you
might be giving a speech at a wedding soon.
Every time I go on Facebook, I feel more
single.
No matter how confident you think you are
speaking in public, there are ways to improve
and gain the trust of your audience.
A big part of this is how you speak.
Like, think about some of the most well-known
speeches of all time.
Martin Luther King Jr.’s “I Have a Dream”
would have been way less effective if he had
stared straight down at the podium.
If you’re giving a presentation, this means
you should avoid reading from the slides or
straight off a page of notes.
This keeps your tone casual and makes sure
that you avoid sounding like a robot.
If you have slides, they should be visual-heavy.
If your audience is reading a ton of information,
you could have sent a memo instead.
Let’s say you were trying to convince someone
that Lemonade was one of the most visually
compelling albums of all time and propelled
Beyoncé to new heights as an artist.
[Like anyone would really need convincing.]
You could tell people that her song “Formation”
won a Grammy for Best Music Video.
But it would be better to show a clip of Queen
Bey in all her glory.
And since you’re confident in what you’re
saying and not reading off your notes, put
those eyes to good use!
Make eye contact with your audience.
Just like on a first date, it shows you care.
And it keeps you from fixating on that fake
plant that’s in the back of every office
meeting room.
If you’re uncomfortable making direct eye
contact, looking at people’s foreheads can
be a good way to fudge it.
Remember how we said content matters more
than formatting in written communication?
Well, when you’re speaking, what you say
is just as important as how you say it.
So, always remember to aim for SUCCES.
Two Cs.
Two Ss.
It’s a 6-step framework that helps you deliver
your points clearly and concisely.
First up, a Simple ‘S.’
Or, the K.I.S.S. method.
Keep it simple, silly.
Identify the one thing you want your audience
to come away with, and stick to that core
message.
You might even craft a memorable sound byte
that summarizes your main points.
For example, if you were trying to convince
someone to watch your favorite TV show, you
might say that “Stranger Things is like
Stand by Me, but with aliens.” or “Psych
is like The Mentalist, but with shenanigans!”
Next, use the Unexpected.
You know those YouTube videos where some
screaming ghoul pops out of nowhere?
Yeah, I’m not gonna do that.
And neither should you.
But do something memorable!
Maybe crack a joke to make a mundane topic
fun, like that one Southwest Airlines flight
safety presentation.
Or highlight a knowledge gap.
Make the audience feel like they need to pay
attention by creating a scenario where they
have to know the answer.
How will this product help me save 15 minutes
during my morning routine?
Why is 42 the meaning of life?
But be careful to avoid gimmicks or misleading
people.
We’ve all been frustrated by clickbait articles
that aren’t what they promised.
Your audience will feel the same way.
Third, anchor your work with something Concrete
Founders of the SUCCES framework use an analogy
called the Velcro Theory of Memory.
The more hooks you have, the more an idea
is going to stick in your brain.
You want to explain your main point using
examples your audience already knows or can
understand, without confusing language.
For example, JFK didn’t say he wanted to
‘increase scientific funding for exploration
of natural satellites in order to increase
the reach of homosapiens.’
He said he wanted to put a man on the Moon.
And if you’re explaining tricky business
concepts, like emotional influence, you might
use pop culture references, like Harry Potter,
to make analogies your audience will remember.
Fourth, to show you did your homework, keep
it Credible.
Facts, figures, and experts will help people
understand what you’re trying to say.
Your audience may want to hear from people
with external credibility, like Ivy League
professors or high-achieving professionals,
like CEOs.
You also need to think about internal credibility,
or the appeal of your argument.
You’ll have low internal credibility if
your message conflicts with the way your audience
sees the world.
So, if you’re a broke college student surviving
on ramen but trying to convince your friends
to eat healthy, you could cite a nutritionist
to explain why the peppers on that Domino’s
pizza do not count as vegetables.
Fifth, make it Emotional.
Make people care.
There’s a reason that those commercials
with Sarah McLachlan are so effective.
To make your message memorable, use something
that pulls on the heartstrings and makes people
think about their own identities.
Are you a kind person who wants to help a
dog in need?
Or, deep down, do you love cats enough to
adopt another?
Finally, make your speech legen -- wait for
it -- dary by telling a great Story.
Stories act like motivators.
Think about how inspired you might feel after
watching a movie about a ragtag team of underdogs
trying to make the playoffs.
And a well-crafted story can also show people
how to act by providing a template or example.
So, for instance, if you were soliciting funding
for the Li’l Sebastian scholarship, you
could tell the story of a Pawnee student who
overcame all odds thanks to the generous donations
of community benefactors.
Now, SUCCES relies heavily on understanding
who your audience is, so you can adjust what
you’re saying to meet their needs.
Just like with writing, it’s helpful to
conduct an audience analysis before you speak.
Understanding who they are will help you build
trust and emotional influence.
And it’s also important that you listen
to what your audience has to say.
Active listening can help you seem more competent
in any conversation.
Focus on the person or people you’re talking
to, whether they’re making a statement or
asking a question.
Try to really understand them before mentally
preparing your response.
Wait for them to finish their thought, no
matter how strongly you feel about a thing.
Interruptions can also be a subtle form of
discrimination, so it’s best to make sure
you’re not accidentally #mansplaining or
anything.
And don’t be afraid of short pauses or silence
-- it can give you time to think.
To make sure you’ve understood someone,
you can try circle speak and paraphrase them
to double-check.
So, if your friend was debating with you about
the best Shondaland show, you might say, “So,
you’re saying you can’t get enough of
the non-stop plot twists in How to Get Away
with Murder?””
And they’ll either say, “exactly!”
Or correct you, and say, “No, you missed
my point.
I watched that show religiously until it was
way too much drama.
My Twitter fingers couldn’t keep up!”
So, now that we’ve covered basically everything
there is to know about speaking publicly,
what would it look like?
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
Let’s say you were a representative from
Harvard Law School.
And you were giving a presentation to a room
of third-year undergraduate women who are
starting to think about what’s next after
graduation.
Your job is to use your stellar speaking skills
to persuade them to consider careers in law.
To be effective, you don’t have to use all
6 parts of SUCCES.
But using 3 or 4 will still help your words
resonate.
Since you’re working with a diverse group
of undergrads who may know very little about
law, you would start with your thesis sentence:
law is a fulfilling career and an incredible
way to change people’s lives.
To show that there’s space in the job market,
you could share some salary and job-growth
projections.
To make your points more relatable, you could
talk about issues affecting women’s rights.
You could reference cases that have personally
impacted women’s lives, like U.S. v. Virginia,
which eliminated VMI’s male-only admissions
policy.
Then, you could share the inspirational story
of Sonya Sotomayor, who grew up in a housing
project in the Bronx and is now a supreme
court justice.
Finally, you’d open it up for questions,
or even debate.
Because you did an audience analysis, you’re
ready for questions about the LSAT, the amount
of school required to become a lawyer, the
cost of education, or even work-life balance.
And you’ve practiced active listening, which
will help you answer any tough questions thrown
your way.
You’ll be calm and concise, even if you’re
mentally scrambling for an answer.
But you know your stuff!
So you can confidently tell them that a secondary
degree is long but rewarding, there’s financial
aid, and women can successfully balance whatever
they want.
Thanks, Thought Bubble!
All these tips are a lot to digest, and the
best way to make sure you’re prepared for
public speaking is practice.
Practice will help you become more comfortable
in low-stakes situations before that important
meeting or thesis defense.
You can even check yourself before you wreck
yourself.
And by that, I mean record yourself practicing.
Now, I get it.
Unless you’re a YouTuber or a screen actor
or something, you probably don’t like seeing
yourself on camera.
And to be honest, it’s still weird for
me.
But it can help you catch things you may be
doing wrong and help you practice what you’re
already doing right.
With a recording it’s really easy to watch
how you’re speaking.
Maybe you didn’t realize that you’re pacing
back and forth a lot, staying glued to one
spot, or gesticulating so much that it’s
almost interpretive dance.
You can also watch for rambling.
I get it.
Nerves are real.
But shaking them off and keeping an even pace
will make sure people understand you.
And since what you say is as important as
how you say it, practicing frequently or with
different people will help you make sure that
none of your main points are confusing.
With that, we’re done talking about talking.
So, if nothing else, remember these key takeaways:
Practice will help you foster good habits,
from how you speak to how you stand.
Aim for SUCCES to make your speech more impactful.
Use active listening to understand your audience’s
questions and ideas, so you can answer competently.
That wraps up our fundamentals.
Next time, we’ll talk about how to apply
your new business knowledge to navigate the
job search.
If you’re fresh out of college and on the
hunt for that dream job or just looking for
something new, you’re in luck!
Crash Course Business is sponsored by Google, and it’s made with the help of all these
nice people and Thought Cafe is our amazing
animation team.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like The Art Assignment, where
host Sarah Urist Green explores art and art history
through the lens of things happening today.
Also, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.